Now that we've seen how to use functions to calculate and return values,
let's see one more example where we can use return values.
This time we'll be generating and returning random numbers;
and random values are really useful in simulating
any real world behavior that involves chance or random events.
Like simulating rolling dice, which we'll get to.
When you roll a six sided dice,
one roll will have a value of either one,
two, three, four, five or six.
But you aren't sure which value it will take for each roll.
There's an element of chance.
So we can use random numbers to generate a random roll value within this range.
But before we get to that, let's learn a little bit more about random values in Java.
To generate random values in Java,
we'll be using a built in math function called random.
This function doesn't take in any parameters,
but it returns a random value that we can then use in our programs.
And like our println function was always attached to system data out,
this math function random is attached to this word math;
which we'll learn more about later.
And this line of code which is a call to random,
outputs a random decimal number between zero and one.
The range of numbers they can output includes zero
but doesn't quite go all the way up to include one;
and each time we call random by saying Math.random ();
this will return a random number;
like one call might return zero,
another 0.5917, another 0.2382,
in any small decimal up to almost one.
Its maximum return value is still going to be a decimal point just
really close to one, something like 0.9999.
And since Math.random returns a random value as output,
we can assign the value of this function call to a variable.
This will be a double because it's a number that involves decimal points,
and let's call this value random number.
And now, we can work with this returned value
to get a more specific range of random values.
For example, we can take the value of our random number,
and multiply it by 10 to get a larger random range.
We know that our random number will be in the range zero to almost one.
So if Math.random outputs its lowest possible value at zero,
we'll have zero times 10 which equals zero for this line of code.
And that will be the minimum value for this range.
And if math.random generates one of its highest values,
which is around 0.999,
if we multiply this by 10,
we'll get 9.99; and that will be our new max.
So we've just changed our range from zero to almost one,
to zero to almost 10 just by multiplying.
Next, if we want to change this range so that we're
generating random integers instead of random doubles,
which are numbers with decimals,
we can cast this value to an int and restoring that value in a variable called randomInt.
Casting means that you're turning one variable type into another.
So when we cast a decimal number,
which for a random number is a type of double, to an int,
this cast will drop whatever decimal value that
original number has and turned that double into an int.
So say a random number has a value of 9.985,
even though this value is close to 10,
when we cast this value to an int,
it will just turn into nine;
and the decimal part .985 will be ignored.
It's the same for other cases.
If our random number is something like 1.252,
this decimal portion, .252,
will be ignored and a cast will turn it into just one.
A value of 0. 5728, we'll have
this whole decimal portion ignored and will turn into the integer zero.
And to do this casting,
we just write our casting type; in this case int,
which we want our number to become;
in parentheses, right before the value we want to change.
In this case, right before the value of random number which starts out as a double.
Now this randomInt that holds the value of our cast random number,
will always be a value in the integer range from 0-9, including nine.
Great, now let's use this knowledge about
casting and changing range of random numbers to help us
write a program that simulates and returns
the correct integer values for randomly rolled dice.